in the last couple of videos we saw that
looking just purely at market
capitalization can be a little bit
misleading when you look at companies
that have a good bit of leverage or
companies that have a good bit of debt
for example if that's the assets of the
company and let's say that they have
this much debt
and this is their equity
this is their
equity
and then let's say they have some excess
cash cash that's not necessary to
actually operate the business i'll draw
that up here so this is excess cash some
cash is necessary and oftentimes people
don't make the distinction and they'll
just
view this as all the cash but we really
want to separate the value of the
enterprise out of the market value of
the equity or the value of the debt so
let me just write all this down so this
right here this is the value of the
business the enterprise value
enterprise value right here is the debt
right there is the debt and this is the
equity
and this is a little bit of a slight
i would say technicality and you don't
have to worry about this if it confuses
you at all is when i write the
enterprise value here this is the value
of the business itself so it's kind of
the the operational assets net of the
operational liabilities it's literally
if you had to go out and in the past few
examples and buy the pizzeria how much
net would you have to pay for that
pizzeria and that's what we're trying to
figure out for when right here when
we're talking about the enterprise value
and we saw in the last couple of videos
how you calculate it but it never hurts
to review it this is actually one of
those less intuitive calculations the
first few times you see it so
it doesn't hurt to do it again
so the first thing to figure out is how
do you figure out the market value of
the equity the book value of the equity
is very easy you could go into a
company's balance sheet and they'll
write down a number they'll say this is
what our our accountants say that our
are the book value of our equity is
worth but the market value figure it out
from what the market's willing to pay
for a share so
if you the market value of equity or the
market cap
is equal to price
per share times the number of shares
and that's the market value of this
equity and you can see just even from
this diagram that the enterprise value
the enterprise value plus
the non-operating cash or investments
or liquid investments whatever you want
to call them enterprise value plus the
cash is equal to
the debt
debt plus
let's just say the market cap right
because we want to know that what we
want to know when we look at a price
we want to be able to figure out what is
the market saying the enterprise value
of the company is what is the market
value of the enterprise so debt plus
instead of equity i'll write market
capitalization because it's the same
thing
market capitalization is the market's
value of the equity plus market cap
so we know market cap we can look up the
debt on a company's balance sheet we can
look up the cash so then we get we just
subtract cash from both sides and we get
enterprise value
is equal to our enterprise value is
equal to i'll put market cap first
market cap
market cap plus debt
minus cash right we're just taking cash
onto the
right hand side of this equation
minus
cash so for example if i have a stock
that is trading at
let's say the price is ten dollars
and let's say that there are shares
let's say there are one million shares
and let's say that the company has
the company has
50 million of debt
and
let's say it has
5 million of cash
of excess cash what's its enterprise
value well you first figure out its
market cap its market cap is 10
per share times a million shares so
that's 10 million shares that's the
market cap
you add the debt so plus 50 million
dollars and once again i said this in
the last video it's very unintuitive
when you figure out the value of the
enterprise to add the debt and the
intuition is that if someone were to
want to buy this company out of from the
stakeholders and be debt-free they would
have to pay these people the total
amount of debt and they would have to
pay these people the total amount of the
market value so they'd have to pay the
debt plus the equity and they get a
refund of the cash right this would be
kind of extra stuff that they would be
buying that they could get money back
for so you have to pay the equity
holders you'd have to pay the debt
holders and then you get a refund of the
cash
and so the enterprise value is what 60
million
minus five
that's
55 million fair enough this is all just
review of the enterprise value video but
the question is now that you've figured
out enterprise value how do you figure
out if that's a fair enterprise value
when you looked at market capitalization
you compared that to earnings right
price to earnings the price to earnings
ratio you're doing this on a per share
this is price per share divided by
earnings per share right this is this
ratio is equivalent to
market cap
divided by
the actual net income of the company
net income of the company where if you
just multiply the numerator and the
denominator by the number of shares you
get market cap and net income this is
eps
pde is actually price per share divided
by earnings per share and that was one
way to look at it you could compare two
companies and we saw it breaks down if
they have different types of capital
structure so what do you compare
enterprise value to here we did market
cap to net income enterprise value
should be compared to what now i made an
argument in the last video that well if
we're looking at the enterprise we
should we should look at essentially at
the earnings that are popping out of the
enterprise we should look at the
earnings that are coming out of this
asset right here
and we're on the very first video on the
income statement i i implied that let's
do a balance sheet you have your revenue
your revenue could be a hundred
you have your
cost of goods sold
cost of goods sold could be
let's say it's a minus 50. and i'll show
you another conventions one of the one
of the uh commenters suggested that i do
this convention which is actually the
most typical convention for a lot of
accountants and financial analysts
instead of writing a negative they'll
write in parentheses that means negative
minus 50
and then the gross profit
gross profit
would be 50.
and then actually i'm going to do
something a little bit interesting let's
say that this cost of goods sold it
involves no depreciation or amortization
and watch those videos if those words
confuse you and all the depreciation and
amortization is actually occurring at
the corporate level so let's say that
there is
uh some
sg a
sgna but this is without the
depreciation and amortization so this is
so let's say that this is an expense of
let's say this is an expense of 10
and let's say there's some depreciation
and amortization as well
d
and a depreciation amortization the last
couple of videos i kind of group and
that tends to be the case on a lot of
income statements they won't separate
the out the depreciation amortization
and you'll actually have to look at the
cash flow statement to figure out what
this is and i'm going to do that in a
future video but let's say that we
actually do break it out sometimes that
does happen and let's say that that's
another
that's another five maybe these are in
thousands
and then you're left with the operating
profit
up
rating profit
in this case which is 50
minus 15 so it's 35 and then you have
things below that you have interest and
i'll do those just for when you have the
non-operating income and interest and
all that let me just do that interest
interest let's say that that is also a
i don't know 5 000 if that's what we
care about
and then you have pre-tax
i didn't put the non-operating income
that this let's say this cash isn't
generating anything so pre-tax income is
30 000 if that's what we're dealing with
it's getting a little messy so then you
have taxes it says 30 let's say it's
so it's ten thousand of taxes and then
you have earnings
earnings
thirty minus ten is twenty thousand
so i suggested what what part of this
income statement is generated is depend
purely on
this piece right here
dependent purely on this piece right
here
well all the stuff with interest that's
dependent on the debt and essentially
taxes is also dependent on the debt
because the more interest you have the
more you can deduct it and and so all of
all of this
down here is dependent on your capital
structure
right so if you wanted to look just what
the enterprise value is generating is
generating the operating profit
it's generating the operating profit
right there
so i suggested that a a pretty good
ratio although this is very
non-traditional it's not very
non-traditional but you don't hear it
said a lot is i i'd argue that you could
look at ev to operating profit as a good
metric
ev to operating profit
operating profit
which in a lot of cases is the is the
inverse of the return on return on
assets as i defined it in the first
video there's a lot of different return
on asset definitions but it's
essentially saying for every dollar of
operating profit how much are you paying
for the enterprise which i think is a
pretty good metric now the more
conventional metric
that you'll see when you you see people
talk about enterprise values enterprise
value to ebitda and if you go and get a
job as a research analyst at some firm
this is going to be something that
you're going to be expected to calculate
for a company and and hopefully talk
reasonably intelligent about it so the
first question to to talk reasonably
reasonably intelligent about anything is
what is ebitda so ebitda is earnings
before
interest taxes depreciation and
amortization so let's let's see what
that would be here so it's earnings
before interest
taxes
depreciation and amortization so it's
before all of this stuff right actually
let's compare that to something that we
covered before so you have ebitda
you have ebitda
and you have ebit
ebit is earnings before interest and
taxes
so ebit is earnings you add back taxes
and interest you're at operating profit
and i've gone over this in the past but
the distinction between operating profit
and ebit is that ebit might include some
non-operating income which i haven't put
here but if this cash was generating
some thing some profit unrelated to the
operations of the business it would be
included in ebit it wouldn't be an
operating profit but they're usually
pretty close if we're talking about a
let's say a non-financial type of
business so this is ebit and then if you
want to get ebitda you just add back the
depreciation and amortization
so ebitda would be here
ee bit da so you would add back the up
the ebit is 35 000 i guess if you add
that back it would be 40 000.
so the ebitda in this case is 40. if
these are my units are in thousands it's
000. now the question is why do people
care about ebitda why is ebitda used
instead of operating profit and the
logic is is that depreciation and
amortization and we did this in that
appreciation and amortization videos
these are just spread out costs that
necessarily aren't cash going out the
door in this period we saw that this
depreciation amortization maybe this is
i bought a a hundred dollar or a hundred
thousand dollar object ten years ago and
every year or let's say and every year i
i depreciate one twentieth of it right
but the cash went out the door 20 years
ago and so this depreciation
amortization in this period it isn't
necessarily cash out of the door in fact
it isn't cash out of the door and we'll
talk in future videos about how do you
find out what the cash out the door is
in a period so it's considered a
non-cash expense
non-cash
so when you figure out ebitda when you
add back taxes you add back interest and
you add back depreciation amortization
what you're left with is essentially how
much raw cash is the enterprise spitting
out so it's raw cash
is it spitting out and a lot of people
care about this because this is an
indication of one the company's ability
to
do things to to do things like pay its
interest pay its taxes or invest in the
business itself or another way to view
it is if you paid if you take
if you if you look at
ev the ebitda you're saying for every
dollar of raw cash that this business
spits out and let's say i were to not
reinvest in the business or or or buy
new equipment if just raw dollars how
much am i paying for the enterprise and
a general rule of thumb and we'll do
more on this in the future i think i'm
already well over my my regular time
limit is that for a very kind of stable
simple
non-declining non-growing business
five times ebitda is considered a good
valuation but what matters more is what
other companies in that industry are
trading at so what all of these ratios
they're they're better as relative
valuation metrics in the future i'll
show you how to do maybe a discounted
cash flow or
discounted free cash flow type of
analysis or dividend discount model or
something so you can kind of figure out
an absolute value but when you're
looking at in public markets you're when
you're picking to decide something
you're also implicitly picking not to
buy other things or you're choosing to
sell something you're also implicitly
choosing not to sell other things so
relative value starts to matter a little
bit more anyway hopefully you found that
helpful